this is a pepper panic saga level 76
walkthrough video
we had a request for this on our
Pepper Panic Tips Facebook page
so I'm going to play the level through
and complete it
I would suggest that you visit our site pepper panic tips
and read our full Pepper Panic Saga level 76
first so that you understand the
strategy a little bit better
a I'm made one of these earlier and
it the time what really long for me to
try to to as quickly as possible
but I'll I'll try to do my best to
explain everything
ago we have to clear the Oasis most
important thing
and we can see we have four green
in the race so that would be the best
color to go with %uh who make this
this for peppermint to the top even
though it in a bad spot
because we also have a pool their
for right now I'm in this match the
green
at the American from the top instead
wheelchairs more brotha I
weight set up a4 paper vertical match
Nadal clear this i straight here
possible drove the red peppers it's
going to remove this being with us
big deal and we got a nice
drop their that's that's an example
why clear out space is so important and
while I get over this ice is so
important because that can happen
for really work rules more now even
though the red
aren't directly or sense that you
I mean or trapped in the ice there are
some that are directly with the statue
for
will go ahead and make matches in order
for because
you might be able to get some it's that
way and they cleared up quite a bit of
space
I think there's a free
we set up this or second said that on
purpose but I did
but we'll take it
know this situation with a4 paper
matches a really is good
this is entrapped in the i say more and
shock waves I can
it they them
but at the same time there's really no
better
so we're good you
the things are pretty jumbled up at the
top so I'm gonna go ahead
make this her poor Mascherano do
vertically cuz that'll bring at least
two ship them papers
I don't wanna make this right match here
because adults per away from the
searchers and also this chain reaction
that this wonderfully from thatcher
summer look for something else instead
a man that's a green its gonna drop the
purple to match with the purple
save I'm so that thats affected
Thursday's
but we still have to clear the screen
here
mutant no bro great choices here
it may be time to this go ahead and
clear the
I'm gonna make the brilliant blue
matching elements saved her to happen
we might be
we might be better off at this point is
clear out this page related gross and
remove first look of
workable
I so that's not a bad result set up a
match here all weekend
get it on through
know your for pepper mash we always look
for these as the initial shock wave a
broker
this is primarily to get rid of the I
but it's also nice because in or create
action and other stuff happens
the in a sense that gives us free moves
to
your as those things are happening with
a losing
america's for this purple because little
drop something
everywhere with the green
my Expo this yellow because that'll set
up the screen
will clear the ice kittens that truth
and now things change pretty
conservative because there's nothing in
the way from
the top to the bottom there's no
the media for pepper LTC matches
them said she's the one who is it for
this one that's going to hit this that
you and it's also your chain
cause a chain reaction this was grateful
it proves that
we've got a little extra in there for an
hour to 30 moves and we really have to
be careful
to make the best choices at this point
because we get a lot of that river
still no shock wave match is available I
am gonna
a member of the Green the greeter set up
pretty good Nexus statues
so it won't be bad to grow the
but as you can see
you can't really focus on those clothes
because things move around
so after each choice you know you really
will look
things over again to see if it's still
good to go that direction
I'm gonna go ahead and do that but it's
not that that's not really I D or
no
no ads it's a little bit better because
it will
actually look at this stature approach a
reaction to a bit more
writer that was in the same cascade to
your couple it either
look over the board and see if there's
any direct matches were the
that's their shoes in when there's no
were down to 10 move
so we really need to create actually as
quickly as possible
Minimates the yellow here its gonna do a
couple different things gonna drop
things down
its gonna set up workers go this blue
it's also going to bring the
the red though
redo the for all appropriate to make
sure that no
new show cleavage is the
with clothes for in
exploiting the blue paper is a really
important there what I was hoping for
in the summer 7 ago got what I got was
a more options with the red because
they're all over the place
here we can choose between red or blue
but since the Red
we're gonna be mmm cool
slightly mean it's pretty close but
they'll be slightly more effective I
think towards clearing out the board on
go
checkup top there's no listener
shockwave met there now so I can take
this forum
at the bottom
in in other situations the a little bit
different
no I guess associate was gonna say it
might be good to look at lose but
the rather just as close to the statues
and we can get an instant
chain reaction and that's a nice place
for that wonderful
okay so now we have but moos
to get once that you but unfortunately
it is probably the most difficult that
you
except for this other one that's in the
same place on the other side
to get to at this point we're going to
those there's nothing at the bottom in
the border that's very effective
so this point we're gonna wanna I'm
reaction again in one thing to note is
that
we make this as well the yellow will
match
they won't movies yellows and we can we
can go back to that later to drop more
papers donahue
cream is also near the statue
which the could come in and they really
isn't a good way to get anything going
with the purple
blue at the moment so we're gonna make
this matter and
or for we're gonna make this person that
he would happen
it's an OU owners want this the your
chill out for
now things are a lot different
we don't want we don't want to start
this
this road reaction but starting with
green or purple will
get us through the level right now so
have to figure out a way to do that in
the next
former
okay so we merge the right here
over are so few minutes the blue hear
that I'm brings together
this workers thats bustle now the bath
now the
the drawback that is this is gonna
explode but we have more grown purple
so the chain reaction is going to i'm
was going to
you
that dropped warmer than dropping up so
that's how you complete the level
hmm
you see it takes combination of all the
things we talk about
prepare it that's guide a this I was not
as hard as it used to be but it's still
difficult so if you're stuck here
that's not the ordinary I hope this
helps them
like I said we did make this as for
request that someone had made our
Facebook page that we
we encourage you to let us know what you
need
and we'll try to 'em develop a new guys
or
you make a video like this if you found
this
the health law would be happy if you
would share it that would help us out
and definitely make sure you like us on
Facebook at school subscribe to our
YouTube channel so you can find out we
make all the throws
lot of new guys coming soon to
check back regularly thanks